Brian Gosling and Harrison Ford our new
favorite Hollywood bromance plus Sam
Smith says his dad did not like stay
with me hey friends Denny here now you
know Fridays have me feeling a certain
kind of way and I am so excited to share
some special tracks for new music Friday
we'll have that for you in just a few
but first Ryan Gosling and Harrison Ford
are on the screen together they're
facing a post-apocalyptic Los Angeles in
Blade Runner 20 49 35 years after the
original which of course start harrison
the film is out now and is getting rave
reviews but the real fun has been the
budding bromance between the two
co-stars their press tour has just been
non-stop laughs watch these two just
unravel during this booze filled
interview with Britain's this morning
host Alison Hammond let's talk about the
movie Blade Runner 2049 cheer up now
look the two have been busting each
other's chops in front of our cameras -
starting way back at San Diego comic-con
this summer how was it working together
how was it what was it like it was
horrible
and then there's also the time Harrison
straight-up drew a blank
when et asked which Gosling film was his
favorite Harrison you said that you
wanted to work with Ryan after seeing a
lot of the work that he'd done was there
one role in particular what was it the
notebook I don't think so no it was I
was a little wild it wasn't I mean the
discipline to learn
the all the dancing all the dance
routines the singing and the keyboard I
love the keyboard and I cannot get
enough of gossington for it I'm telling
you they need to take their act on the
road immediately okay thanks all right
another blockbuster making some waves
today Pacific Rim uprising the new
trailer for the sequel just dropped at
New York Comic Con and it is epic
take a look there's something you need
to see
[Applause]
well he's pretty big dope right John
boyega plays a son of Aegeus Alba's
character from the original and he told
the crowd at Comic Con that the vision
of this movie was to build upon and
expand upon the universe adding that
this is sacred ground and fans of
Guillermo del Toro's first movie will be
pleased all right moving on from movies
to music
Sam Smith revealed the cover art a name
of his second album it's called the
thrill of it all he also announced tour
dates and I'm telling you Sam I am
coming to see you live by hook or crook
not that one enough he also dropped his
second single ahead of his SNL
performance and I got to tell you we are
catching fils on this new one called
prey
[Music]
maybe
Churchill not one folks are Sam says a
lot of his family stories are on this
next album and are very much a part of
his new music in fact Sam told our
friends at radio.com that his family can
be very honest about his work and
they're really honest with me and you
know when they're not feeling something
let me know and I'll disagree with them
my dad hated stay with me when I played
that well you proved your dad wrong with
that one Sam meanwhile lin-manuel
Miranda recruited an all-star list of
Latino artists for his benefit song
almost like praying the song was
released Thursday night and features
singers Jennifer Lopez Marc Anthony and
glorious Stefan just name a few
take a listen
[Music]
it's only a bonus that the song is also
a jammer because proceeds that the
single will go directly to Hispanic
Federation org to help those in Puerto
Rico affected by Hurricane Maria all
right country stars Maren Morris and
Vince Gill are also lending their voices
and their new duet it's a heartfelt
emotional plea to don't hate
[Music]
three and then go through these holes
but I hate to tell you
[Music]
who's gonna conquer all
this song could not be coming at a
better time so there you guys have it
it's been a tough week for all of us but
I am wishing you a great weekend and go
out and spread that love and we'll see
you guys on Monday goodbye